und damit kommen wir zu einem ganz
anderen Thema die afd-fraktion möchte
eine onkit-kommission zur Zukunft der
medienordnung und des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks in
Deutschland im Zeitalter umfassenden
Wandels der öffentlichen Kommunikation
und des Medien und Pressewesens
einsetzen möchte dass dort 19
Bundestagsmitglieder 19 Sachverständige
drin sitzen die sich dann damit
beschäftigen wie diese medienordnung der
Zukunft aussehen kann da soll es um
Arbeits- und Produktionsbedingungen im
Journalismus gehen um einen sogenannten
haltungsjournalismus und auch um die
Notwendigkeit Zulässigkeit und
Legitimität eines Gebühren finanzierten
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk also zum
Beispiel um uns und da werden wir jetzt
auch mit einem ersten Redner aus der
afd-fraktion starten das ist Martin
Erwin Renner der medienpolitische
Sprecher der afd-fraktion
Präsidium sehr verehrte Damen
sehr geehrte Herren wir reden hier und
jetzt über den Zustand
und die Zukunft der medienordnung und
des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks in
Deutschland
unsere medienordnung entstammt der
analogen Steinzeit
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
entstammt der medialen des medialen
Mittelalters doch die digitale
Revolution der Neuzeit zwingt alle
Medien ins Internet und das schafft
einen Haufen Probleme
juristische politische kulturelle und
auch gesellschaftliche der Medien und
kommunikationsbericht der
Bundesregierung hat das schon im Jahr
2018 sehr deutlich aufgezeigt dort steht
erstens das Internet ist global angelegt
doch der demokratische Diskurs findet
nach wie vor auf nationaler Ebene statt
zweitens die Medien auch als vierte
Gewalt bezeichnet haben einen
unverzichtbaren demokratischen Auftrag
zu erfüllen
stimmt alles ich sage die Medien sollen
die Kontrolleure der politischen Macht
sein und nicht die Herolde der politisch
Mächtigen nur der Transport aller
Informationen durch die Medien
ermöglicht die öffentliche freie
Meinungsbildung und das ist die
Voraussetzung zur demokratischen
Teilhabe des Bürgers nur der Transport
in der Medienpolitik ist dann auch
gleichzeitig Gesellschaftspolitik der
Deutsche Bundestag die Legislative hat
sich deshalb zu solchen fundamentalen
Fragestellungen unserer Demokratie und
eine zeitgemäße Meinung zu bilden und
Regelungen zu beschließen wenn wir über
die Medien sprechen dann natürlich auch
über den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
sie sind die mit Zwangsgebühren voll
betankten Schlachtschiffe unserer Medien
bemannt mit Haltung starten Journalisten
Matrosen das weiß sogar tomburow
wenn er zwar nicht als Intendant des WDR
sondern als Privatmann auftritt und eine
Rede zum Zustand unseres Rundfunks hält
an dieser Stelle einen ganz
ausdrücklichen Dank für seine wichtige
und zukunftsweisende Rede jüngst in
Hamburg
er fordert eine Reform des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks und
zwar jetzt und nicht erst in zehn Jahren
die übergroße Mehrheit der Bürger möchte
den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk in
dieser Ausgestaltung nicht mehr
und schon gar nicht mit Zwangsgebühren
ausgestattet und finanziert wir wissen
woher diese Unmut der Bürger kommt
werden heutzutage alle verfügbaren
Informationen transportiert nein wir
hatten heute alle politisch und
gesellschaftlich relevanten Gruppen
abgebildet objektiv und neutral nein
erleben wir in den Medien tatsächlich
diese hochgepriesene
Meinungsvielfalt nein
wird die Gesellschaft durch die Medien
in gute Menschen und böse Menschen
gespalten ja
auf der rauen See der wahren
Meinungsvielfalt der echten
Ausgewogenheit der kontroversen Debatten
und der wirklichen Objektivität in der
Informationsvermittlung haben gerade die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Schlachtschiffe
massive Risse im Rumpf und bereits
besorgniserregende Schlagseiten die
Haltung Journalisten auf diesen
Schlachtschiffen haben mitnichten die
Aufgabe die Meinung der politischen der
politisch herrschenden zur herrschenden
Meinung in der Gesellschaft zu machen
sondern vielmehr haben sie die Aufgabe
zu prüfen und gegebenenfalls in Frage zu
stellen ja die digitale Transformation
bedeutet jetzt die große Fahrt auf die
Weltmeere im Internet
die letzten kleinen Schiffchen der einst
wirkt mächtigen vielfältigen und
meinungsbildenden Printmedien treffen
jetzt im Netz auf die global agierenden
oligopolen auf die Plattformbetreiber
des Big Data des Big Money des Big
Business
und gleichzeitig und noch dazu werden
die darbenden Printmedien durch die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen immer weiter
abgedrängt und vielleicht letztlich
versenkt im jüngsten Medien und
kommunikationsbericht der
Bundesregierung 2021 sinniert man
bereits über die Umsetzung und
Machbarkeit von kooperativen
Medienplattformen im Netz es dürfen also
manche Printmedien als begleitboden
mitschippern an der Seite der
öffentlich-rechtlichen Schlachtschiffe
die über einen mit 8,4 Milliarden Euro
prall gefüllten Zwangsgebühren Tank
verfügen doch nach welchen Kriterien
soll denn diese Auswahl dann getroffen
werden dieser Begleitboote spielt das
parteieeigentum an den Medien Verlagen
hier eine Rolle oder eher doch
ideologische Kameraderie demnächst also
öffentlich-rechtliches Internet
also eine noch stärkere Verbrüderung von
Politik und Medien zur wirksamen
Bevormundung und Erziehung der Bürger
und das meine Damen und Herren wäre der
das Ende der notwendigen
Meinungsvielfalt ein Wort für die
Demokratie und deshalb fordern wir eine
solche orchesterkommission die alle
diese juristischen diese kulturellen
dem Parlament zur Verfügung stellt um
ordentliche Entscheidungen zu treffen
dankeschön
nach unseren Regeln wenn ich durchaus
bewugt nach der dritten Aufforderung
sofort ihn auch das Wort zu entziehen
ich will das nur an dieser Stelle
anmerken
Martin Erwin Renner war das aus der
afd-fraktion Präsidenten welche sie
nicht angesprochen haben hier im Stuhl
zu rügen wenn es da was zu Rügen gibt
ist der Ort der Ältestenrat eine weitere
solche Auffälligkeit und dann gibt es
einen Ordnungsruf der nächste Redner ist
der Abgeordnete Helge Lindt für die
SPD-Fraktion und Helge Lindt ist Kultur
und medienpolitischer Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wenn es ihnen ja als AFD
ernsthaft um die gegenwärtigen Skandal
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
ginge also um Fragen von Korruption
Untreue vorteilsname Nepotismus dann
würden sie das ja in irgendeinem Wort in
ihrem Vortrag oder in dem Antrag erwähnt
haben sie tun das aber nicht und das ist
äußerst verräterisch sie kommen sofort
zur Grundsatzdebatte zu allgemeinen
Ausführung über die Situation des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks über
die angebliche linkslastigkeit und all
das und diese Form dieser extrem
durchschaubaren Instrumentalisierung
wenn Sie Ihren Abgesang auf den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk singen
die ist verwerflich sie ist unredlich
und sie ist übrigens unredlich egal wer
das betreibt denn kein Mensch kann mir
erklären inwiefern diese Skandale
heftigen Skandale von Situation von
Missbrauch öffentlicher Gelder von
Missbrauch von Beiträgen dadurch
bearbeitet würde dass wir jetzt Debatten
führen über die Zahl von
rundfunkorchestern über die
Programmgestaltung oder ähnliches das
sind zwei getrennte Debatten und es ist
einfach unsauber unredlich und reiner
Missbrauch das so miteinander zu
verbinden und kommen wir dann zu ihren
inhaltlichen Ausführungen die ja im
Mittelpunkt dessen stehen es ist ja ein
rein gesinnungspolitischer Ansatz den
Sie hier vorgestellt haben sie beklagen
ja dass immer im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk bestimmte
Opfergruppen zu stark erscheinen betonen
so märtyrerhaltung und Viktimisierung
sie sind aber die Großmeister der
vektimisierung und gerieren sich hier
eben wieder als die Märtyrer die
Ankämpfen gegen das Establishment sie
leben aber von diesem establishmen ohne
dieses Establishment sehr ist keiner von
ihnen hier sie sollten also dankbar sein
und nicht die treten den sie ihre
Existenz verdanken unserem
Meinungsfreiheit ist so groß und die
Freiheit dass wir sogar sie erdulden und
sie die Möglichkeit haben hier sprechen
zu können
zum zweiten prangern sie ja in ihr
Begründung ihres Antrags auch die
kulturkämpfer im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und im journalismus-band es
gibt aber keine größeren kulturkämpfer
als sie und was ist wenn man behauptet
es gäbe kulturkämpfer ist Wirklichkeit
aber selbst ist das nennt man
Doppelmoral sie sind also auch die
Weltmeister der Doppelmoral dritter
Punkt sie klagen ja in den Reihen des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks auch
hier sehe ich nicht den Zusammenhang zu
den gegenwärtigen Skandalen sie klagen
Identitätspolitik an
wer macht denn in diesem Haus und in
diesem Land mehr Identität zubereiten
und Identitätspolitik als sie insofern
formulieren sie da offensichtlich eine
Anklage gegen sich selbst und dann der
nächste Punkt vierter Punkt auch das
wieder in ihren Elogen jetzt längstlich
zum ersten Mal wahrzunehmen sie
kritisieren wie im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
dramatisiert wurde wie skandalisiert
würde wie einzelne Themen Klima ich habe
die Uhr angehalten gestatten Sie eine
Frage oder Bemerkung aus der
selbstverständlich selbstverständlich
freue mich
Marc jung aus der afd-fraktion der
kulturpolitische Sprecher Dankeschön
Herr lind dass sie die Frage zulassen
sie sagen hier sie wir hätten die
Skandale die aktuellen Skandale die in
der Tat haarsträuben sind im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk nicht
angesprochen sie haben wahrscheinlich
die letzte Debatte hier nicht verfolgt
oder waren sie nicht anwesend wo wir das
ausführlich getan haben sowohl Kollege
Renner als auch ich
und sie
werfen uns vor sozusagen damit
Populismus zu betreiben also es genauer
Gegenteil wäre doch der Fall also wenn
wir das jetzt hier gemacht hätten dann
werden sie jetzt wieder mit dem
Populismus vor Wurf gekommen und
sozusagen diese ernsthafte dieser Blick
auf die Struktur das ist es doch worum
es uns hier allen zu tun sein muss und
jetzt frage ich sie glauben Sie nicht
dass dieses Skandale eben möglich
geworden sind weil es in den Strukturen
hakt weil dort Verfilzungen stattfinden
seit Jahrzehnten weil die Aufsichtsräte
nicht funktionieren etc weil sie eben
politisch besetzt sind ist das nicht der
Grund weswegen ist zu diesen Skandalen
gekommen sind oder wollen sie das alles
abstreiten und dann noch eine Frage zu
ihrer Aussage wir würden uns hier in der
Opferrolle gerieren ich frage es jetzt
mal ganz objektiv wissen Sie wie viele
afd-exponenten im vergangenen Jahr in
den öffentlich-rechtlichen Talkshows zu
Wort gekommen sind und haben sie das mal
in Relation gesetzt mit den Exponenten
ihrer Partei oder die Grünen der Grünen
Partei die deutlich auch damals noch
kleiner war als wir haben sie das getan
und wenn ja sind sie zum Schluss
gekommen dass es alles gerecht so und es
ist genau richtig so dass die AFD
ausgeschlossen wird aus der öffentlichen
Debatte bitte nehmen Sie mal Stellung zu
diesen zwei Punkten dankeschön ich danke
ausdrücklich für diese Frage die mir
wunderbare Vorlagen gibt deswegen ist
das so eine Dienstleistung ihrerseits
zum einen haben sie es ja selbst benannt
also ich muss das gar nicht aussprechen
sie haben aber Populismus gleich benannt
also sie benennen gleich selbst das was
sie tun dafür bin ich ihnen erstmal
dankbar zum zweiten
wenn Sie diese Kausalität ja sehen also
wie sie ihm ausgeführt haben dass jetzt
ihre Ausführung hier auch in dem Antrag
zur Einrichtung einer onkel-kommission
im unmittelbaren Zusammenhang mit dem
Skandalen um Machtmissbrauch
Verschwendung von Mitteln sogar
kriminellen direkten wäre warum
schreiben Sie das nicht in den Antrag
hinein und warum hat Herr Renner das
nicht hier ausgeführt es ist eine etwas
dünne Begründung dass sie in der
vergangenen Debatte das getan hätten sie
haben es hier nicht getan insofern muss
ich Sie leider an dem messen was sie
hier vorgetragen haben und was hier
vorliegt und im übrigen würde es selbst
wenn sie es töten logisch überhaupt
nicht funktionieren denn ihre ganzen
Ausführung eben in der Rede in diesem
Antrag haben überhaupt nichts zu tun und
bringen kein Millimeter Fortschritt bei
der Bekämpfung der Missstände über die
wir reden und das ist ja der Verrat den
sie begehen und das finde ich es
besonders sie verraten die mit
Erwartungen des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks doppelt nämlich indem sie
nicht den öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und all diejenigen die da
arbeiten unterstützen in ihrer
tagtäglichen Arbeit diejenigen die nicht
betrogen haben sondern die für die
Demokratie hier mit kritischen
Journalismus Arbeiten und zum zweiten
tun Sie so als ob deren Situation
verbessert würde durch ihren Antrag
mitnichten ist das der Fall und zum
nächsten Punkt
da haben sie auch vorgeführt was ich
gesagt habe deshalb war das hier so eine
Art performative Bestätigung meiner
Ausführung ich habe hier gesagt sie
gerieren sich als Märtyrer sie haben das
verneint und haben dann eben selbst
wieder sich als Märtyrer dargestellt das
finde ich etwas selbst widersprüchlich
die AFD kann sich wahrlich nicht
beschweren über Präsenz im privaten wie
im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
dieses Land bietet Ihnen als erklärten
Gegnern der Demokratie und dieser ihrer
Werte in diesem Land reichlich Raum und
sie bietet auch ihren Paralleluniversen
all ihren Kanälen die sie bedienen
Möglichkeiten die Plattform die sie dort
zitieren Achse des Guten Tisch ist
eigentlich und so weiter sind die
verboten sind die untersagten nein Sie
können Ihren Irrsinn und ihren
wienersinn und ihren Rassismus und ihren
Populismus täglich unbeschränkt in
dieses Rand Garant hinausblasen also
hören Sie endlich auf mit diesem
unerträglichen mimosenhaften
Selbstmitleid
und das ist es ja nämlich sie klagen
andere an und behaupten die würden
dramatisieren und die würden ihr
Schicksal das ist ja auch ihr
Geschäftsmodell Minderheiten würden ihr
Schicksal in Vordergrund stellen sie
sind es doch sie sind doch die
dramaqueens par excellence der deutschen
Politik in ihrem Auftreten und das auch
noch in einer extrem patriarchalen Form
und kommen wir weiter zu ihrer nicht
nachvollziehbaren wenn sie ja und ich
versuche ja mich hineinzudenken in ihr
Paralleluniversum und ihnen Antrag wenn
sie ja behaupten dass die ganze
plattformisierung und
oligoligolisierung Sie aufregt sie
bekümmert warum wollen sie dann genau
das was ein Korrektiv darstellt nämlich
Qualitätsjournalismus nämlich ein
starker guter öffentlicher rechtlicher
Rundfunk abwickeln warum wollen Sie dies
Gegenmittel gegen die toxischen
Entwicklung die angeblich sie so
besorgen einfach beenden das ist
scheinheilig und auch das ist wieder
doppelmoralisch und widersprüchlich
kurzum wenn das so käme was sie da
fordern wenn also diese onkelett
letztlich das Ergebnis brächte was sie
sich wünschen dann hätten wir
tatsächlich eine Landschaft in der
Desinformation und Hass viel größere
Freiräume hätten dass wir für Sie sich
eine bequeme Situation die Pointe ist
aber glaube ich dass sie das sich gar
nicht unbedingt wünschen Sie wünschen
gar nicht dass der öffentlich rechtlich
Rundfunk verschwindet denn ihr Business
Case ist ja dass sie als
anti-establishment diesen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk immer
wieder Anklagen können und in dieser
selbstgewählten Rolle des Anklägers sich
so großartig finden deshalb wollen sie
auch gar nichts ändern sie sind Null
interessiert an faktische Reform ihm
kommt es darauf an Anklagen
skandalisieren und popularisieren zu
können das ist der Punkt dahinter
deswegen
glaube ich auch dürfen wir diesen Druck
den sie versuchen zu erzeugen nicht
nachgehen übrigens auch nicht in reines
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks ich
warne davor dass Sender sich unter Druck
setzen lassen und in voraus einem
Gehorsam diesem Druck auch nur ein
bisschen nachgeben bekanntlich ist
sprichwörtlicher Selbstmord aus Angst
vor dem Tode kein gutes
medienpolitisches Konzept und deshalb
sollte man das auch nicht anwenden und
im übrigen das erlauben Sie mir auch
noch als jemand der ausdrücklich für
Reformen beim Programm ist auch für mehr
Partizipation ich finde wir sollten mal
die Verhältnismäßigkeit auch sehen
wir haben Revolution jetzt im Iran und
an vielen anderen Stellen aber sicher
nicht löst eine Rede im überseeclub im
Hamburg eine Revolution aus also lassen
wir da mal die Kirchendorf zum nächsten
wenn sie so den Untergang der Demokratie
beschwören hier sehen dass die Freiheit
auf dem Spiel steht dass wir ein
essentielles Problem hätten mit der
ganzen Struktur des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks wo
haben wir denn wirkliche Probleme fragen
Sie mal die Opfer des NSU die seit
Jahrzehnten nicht eine Berücksichtigung
erfahren fordern sie dafür
onkel-kommission nein oder Hanau das
sind essentielle Fragen und Skandale die
Demokratie aber gewiss nicht der Zustand
des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
also hören wir auf mit dieser Politik
der politischen Instrumentalisierung
hören sie auf damit plötzlich runde
Tische zu begrüßen und große
gesellschaftliche Debatten wo sie das
sonst immer ablehnen das ist
durchschaubar das zerstört Vertrauen in
die Politik und damit machen Sie genau
das was Sie am öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk kritisieren vielen Dank
zeige Lindt der Kultur- und
medienpolitische Sprecher und auf ihn
vor Christiane schenderlein die Kultur
und medienpolitische Sprecherin der
Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
vergangenen Woche gab es tatsächlich
eine viel zitierte Rede eines
Intendanten der durchaus den Finger in
die Wunde legte und seine Art runden
Tisch forderte für die Zukunft zu
Diskussionen für die Zukunft des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks aber es
gab auch eine andere Nachricht die gar
nicht so sehr viel Beachtung fand die
aber auch für die Zukunftsdiskussion ein
ganz konkreten zu gewinnen darstellt und
zwar gab das ZDF bekannt die eigenen
Algorithmen für Ihre Mediathek
offenzulegen seit vergangener Woche
können Nutzerinnen und Nutzer genau
nachlesen wie ihre persönlichen
Empfehlungen zustande kommen und im
Gegensatz zu großen Internetplattformen
Zielen die Algorithmen des
öffentlich-rechtlichen eben nicht auf
Vorlieben und Häufigkeit nein
es werden immer auch Angebote gemacht
die über den Horizont hinausgehen das
heißt keine filterblasen keine
Echokammern und keine gleichgerichteten
Informationsangebote und genau das ist
die Leistung unseres
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks der ist
auch immer wieder neu beweisen muss und
sich fragen muss schafft er es die
Menschen mit ihrem Programmangebot und
sein Programmangebot umfassend
vielseitig und von fundiert zu
informieren und erreicht er es
tatsächlich alle Menschen zu erreichen
und besonders in Krisensituationen wie
der corona-krise den Krieg in der
Ukraine und Energiekrise sind eben nicht
Meinungen oder fake-bilder entscheiden
sondern richtige Fakten wichtig das ist
die Grundlage für die eigene
Meinungsbildung und im Kern geht es also
um die Objektivität Meinungsvielfalt und
Ausgewogenheit und es ist tatsächlich so
zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung über zwei
Drittel Vertrauen der Berichterstattung
des öffentlich-rechtlichen und die
Anzahl auf die Zugriffe der
öffentlich-rechtlichen
Nachrichtenportale ist beachtlich
doch nicht erst seit den aufgedeckten
Missständen an der Spitze des rbb rollt
eine Welle von Kritik über den ÖAR
hinweg und auch wir als cdu/csu
Bundestagsfraktionen sind kritisch und
aber auch überzeugt wenn wir nicht jetzt
ernsthaft etwas an den Strukturen ändern
wird die Akzeptanz des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
schwinden und genau darin
sehe ich eine Gefahr
denn dort wo es keinen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gibt
erleben wir polarisierende
Gesellschaften wir erleben ein
Zurückgehen von Partizipation von
demokratischen Entscheidungen und eine
Radikalisierung der Gesellschaft nur
der Bundestag der Bundestag ist für
diese Debatte allerdings genau der
falsche Ort denn für den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sind
allein die Landesparlamente zuständig
und
und vor diesem Hintergrund ist der
Antrag als Ganzes als unzulässig zu
bewerten die Minister
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
den Ländern haben sich im Oktober auf
einen neuen medienstaatsvertrag geeinigt
und bereits 2016 wurde die Arbeitsgruppe
der Länder zum Thema Auftrag und
strukturoptimierung der
Rundfunkanstalten eingesetzt und sie
hatten den Auftrag eine Reform
auszuarbeiten und im Ergebnis der
Auftrag wird geschärft der
Online-Auftrag fortentwickelt die Sender
können mehr Programme ins Internet
verlagern und die Aufsichtsgremien
erhalten auch mehr Aufgaben so können
Sie und sollen sie die Qualität des
Programms kontrollieren und in einem
zweiten Teil des Reformprozesses geht es
um die Finanzierung und das ist ja auch
richtig denn die Finanzierung folgt dem
Auftrag das ist das
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil was
entscheidend ist und was in ihrem Antrag
auch nicht beachtet wird und was den
Prozess anbelangt gehört natürlich der
Wahrheit dazu dass der ganz große Wurf
zur Strukturreform damit noch nicht
getan ist denn die Effizienz das heißt
die Frage welche Sender welchen Programm
Auftrag erfüllen sollen diese Debatte
müssen die Länder die Rundfunkkommission
und die Sender gemeinsam miteinander
führen das heißt die Frage nach dem ob
die stellt sich nicht das wie ist zu
diskutieren und wir stehen zu einem auf
die allgemein von der Allgemeinheit
finanzierten öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks und im afd-antrag hingegen
wird das offen in Frage gestellt da
heißt es Einschätzung der Notwendigkeit
Zulässigkeit und Legitimität eines
Gebühren finanzierten
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks das ist
eine Offenbarung wozu brauchen sie dann
noch eine Kommission und das ist auch
schon angesprochen worden sie
proklamieren stets die angebliche
Staatsnähe des öffentlich-rechtlichen
und versuchen dann aber genau in die
Gremien eben dieser Medien
hineinzugelangen das ist ein klarer
Widerspruch
die Angriffe auf die Pressefreiheit bis
hin zur Zensur das ist oft das erste
Mittel von Antidemokraten Diktatoren und
Kriegsherren und Ast am Mittwoch bei den
Gedenkveranstaltungen zum 9 November
haben wir uns auf die Werte Freiheit und
Demokratie besonnen und eine
entscheidender Grundpfeiler zur
Bewahrung dieser Werte ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und das
Resümee an den Grundpfeilern unserer
Demokratie dürfen wir nicht rütteln und
das sollten Sie auch aus der Geschichte
gelernt haben
Christiane schenderlein hat hier noch
einmal die Notwendigkeit auch eines
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks in der
Demokratie erwähnt
er hat Grunde spricht nun als nächstes
der Kultur- und medienpolitische
Sprecher von Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren die Intention des
vorliegenden Antrags ist mehr als
durchsichtig hier soll ein wichtiges
Instrument parlamentarischer Kontrolle
zu show-veranstaltung degradiert werden
das der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
sich in einem fortlaufenden
Reformprozess befindet spielt für sie da
drüben auch gar keine Rolle schließlich
ist nicht Reform ihr Ziel sondern das in
Frage stellen und Zerstören des
öffentlich-rechtlichen der ÖR ist all
denen ein Dorn im Auge die sich vor den
Fakten fürchten die die Klimakatastrophe
und die Pandemie für Erfindungen halten
und die die globalen Krisen im
breitbandnewsfieber Weg fantasieren
wie die Strategie Rechtsaußen
funktioniert sieht man wenn man zum
Beispiel nach Ungarn schaut private
Medien werden davon orbanfreunden
aufgekauft außerhalb von Budapest gibt
es kein Radio Fernsehen keine Zeit um
die nicht von Orban oder seinen Kumpels
kontrolliert wird unabhängige
JournalistInnen werden als Agenten
diffamiert bei meinem Besuch in Polen
vor einigen Monaten war auch die
staatlich gelenkten Medien ein Thema es
ist eine Tatsache dass sämtliche
Regionalzeitungen in der Hand
regierungsnahe Konzerne sind damit fehlt
in diesen beiden Ländern etwas ganz
Entscheidendes
Regierungskontrolle durch freie und
handlungsfähige Medien und
faktenbasierte Kritik an den politischen
Akteurinnen so ein Mediensystem mit
Maulkorb und Fußfesseln wünschen sich
vielleicht die antragstellenden hier das
wird mit uns aber nicht geben
zur diversen Medienlandschaft in
Deutschland gehört der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk er ist
eine tragende Säule unserer Demokratie
ein Garant für Freiheit und Vielfalt wer
seine Legitimität und Funktion in Frage
stellt der gefährdet Grundprinzipien
unserer Gesellschaft der ÖR ist keinem
parteiinteresse verpflichtet
es kann Ihnen zum Beispiel passieren
dass sie an einem unschuldigen
Dienstagabend wie zum Beispiel am 20
September diesen Jahres beim
Maischberger einen Auftritt von Alice
Weidel
und wenn sie den menschlichen Impuls des
Umschaltens folgen dann bei Markus Lanz
Frau Wagenknecht mit ihren steilen
Thesen sehen können
das mag als Erlebnis schon schmerzhaft
sein aber egal es ist die Vielfalt der
Meinungen auch wenn sie abstrus sind und
dafür stehen die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
ja man darf in Deutschland alles sagen
aber muss es dann auch ertragen und darf
nicht rumheulen wenn man Gegenwind
bekommt
es sind JournalistInnen die nach ihren
handwerklichen Standards und ihrem Kodex
unabhängig entscheiden worüber sie und
wie sie berichten und das ist
entscheidend für unsere Demokratie
entscheidend für unser Land die
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender sind eine
starke Antwort auf demokratiefeindliche
Entwicklungen wir wollen die
Meinungsbildung nicht milliardenschweren
Konzernen wie Google und Facebook
überlassen die eigene wirtschaftliche
Interessen über die Belange des
Gemeinwohls stellen wir wollen in
Deutschland keine meinungsägemonie von
Akteuren wie Fox News die ihr
Geschäftsmodell in der Spaltung der
Gesellschaft gefunden haben ARD und ZDF
bieten eine verlässliche und attraktive
Grundlage für öffentliche
Meinungsbildungsprozesse denn nur mit
einer gemeinsamen faktenbasis können wir
über politische Lösungen diskutieren
wenn diese Basis fehlt herrscht die
Diktatur der alternativen Fakten und
dieser Diktatur stellen wir uns entgegen
doch zurück zu ihren Forderungen der
öffentlich-rechtliche muss nicht einmal
wie sie sagen einer bestandsabnahme
unterzogen werden muss ich fortlaufend
weiterentwickeln das tut er und das
werden wir weiter vorantreiben der ÖAR
hat längst verstanden dass sie ein
ständig lernendes System sein muss wenn
er technisch state of the art und am
Puls der Zeit sein will dieser ständige
Reformprozess findet statt über den
medienstaatsvertrag von der von den
ministerpräsidentinnen verhandelt und
von allen Landtagen angenommen werden
muss zu Recht sind es bei uns die Länder
die übersendeformate ihres Rundfunks
nicht aber über die Inhalte seiner
Berichterstattung entscheiden denn als
Lehre aus dem Nationalsozialismus darf
es nie wieder ein zentrales staatlich
gesteuertes Massenmedium geben das
Reformen im öffentlich-rechtlichen
notwendig sind stellt niemand in Frage
ebenso wenig wie die Notwendigkeit mehr
Transparenz schlägt die Compliance
Regeln Stärkung und Professionalisierung
der Aufsichtsgremien ist selbstreden für
uns ist besonders wichtig dass die
Beschäftigten in den Redaktionen in
ihrer Arbeit weiter gestärkt werden das
beinhaltet natürlich die Stärkung von
Mitbestimmung und die Verbesserung von
Arbeitsbedingungen rotierende
Chefredaktionen sind kein Tabu und
gespart werden kann ganz bestimmt auf
den Leitungsebenen aber eben nicht
zulasten der Mitarbeitenden und der
Qualität der journalistischen Arbeit
zentral für die öffentliche Debatte über
den Auftrag des ÖRR sind weitere
institutionalisierte dialogformate mit
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wo die
NutzerInnen Ihre Bedürfnisse einbringen
können und der gesellschaftliche Auftrag
des öffentlich-rechtlichen diskutiert
werden kann
meine Damen und Herren hier Rechtsaußen
sie
die in der mangelung eigener originärer
Gedanken hier die Parolen von Steve
Bannon nachplappern wollen eine Bühne
für ihr Schmierentheater bekommen das
werden wir im Deutschen Bundestag nicht
zulassen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
Erhard Grundel war das hier in der
Debatte zu einer onkette-kommission die
sich mit der medienordnung beschäftigen
soll und da wäre natürlich auch der
öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk ein wichtiger Aspekt Petra
Sitte spricht nun für die Linksfraktion
sie ist die medienpolitische Sprecherin
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Überraschung die AFD will mal wieder
eine on-cat-kommission einrichten ich
hatte bereits das zweifelhafte Vergnügen
die AFD in einer on-cat-kommission zu
erleben Zusammenfassung nicht präsent
oft körperlich nicht aber vor allem
inhaltlich nicht warum sollte das
diesmal anders sein vielleicht deshalb
weil sie die medienordnung eifernd
bekämpfen dabei nutzen sie wie keine
andere Partei die Kollegen haben es
bereits angedeutet diese medienordnung
genau für Ihre Zwecke sie verbreiten
Fake News sie setzen auf Hass sie setzen
auf Hetze um Menschen herabzusetzen
einzuschüchtern und zu bedrohen
sie haben
sie haben zu dem maßgeblichen Anteil
daran dass ich Menschen im Netz
radikalisieren und schließlich auch
ermutigt werden Anschläge zu verüben wir
haben gerade in Halle das dritte Mal
Jana lange und Kevin schwarze der Opfer
des rechtsterroristischen Anschlags auf
die jüdische Synagoge und den Söhne
Döner Imbiss gedacht dieser Täter hatte
sich maßgeblich im Netz radikalisiert
und ausgerechnet die AFD ausgerechnet
die AFD sorgt sich um die medienordnung
erst legen sie Feuer und dann spielen
Sie sich hier als löschbrigade oft ne
und übrigens zum Umgang mit den großen
Plattformen liegen seit Jahren
Vorschläge vor da haben wir weniger ein
aufklärungs-problem
bemerkenswert ist ebenso dass erst im
die letzten beschlusspunkte ihres
Antrages ihren wunderbaren
Lieblingsfeind den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
thematisieren aber im begründungstext
wird es deutlich fangen sie nämlich
genau damit an es wird also klar dass
sie zugleich nicht verstehen wollen
warum der öffentlich-rechtliche förderal
organisiert wurde weil eben nach Göbbels
zentralistischer
Propagandamaschinerie die Medien
dezentral und demokratisch aufgestellt
sein sollten also liegen wesentliche
Entscheidungskompetenzen gar nicht in
diesem Haus der Kollege hat gesagt
sondern vor allem bei den Bundesländern
wir können da mitwirken aber eine an
cat-kommission im Bundestag wäre das
genau falsche Zeichen letztlich ist in
diesem Antrag das sei ausdrücklich
angemerkt an keiner Stelle von den
Medien schaffenden die Rede weder
bezogen auf ihre soziale Situation noch
auf ihre Arbeitsbedingungen vor Ort es
sind vorwiegend
afd-naheveranstaltungen auf denen
Medienschaffenden nur noch unter
Begleitung von Sicherheitsdiensten
arbeiten können Fazit der Antrag ist
weder inhaltlich zustimmungsfähig noch
vor dem Hintergrund ihrer
medienpolitischen Vorstellungen
glaubhaft sie wollen den Bundestag als
Plattformen nutzen um die medienordnung
nach dem Vorbild Putins Erdogans Orbans
oder ihren sonstigen rechtsextremen
gesinnungsfreunden einzugrenzen keine
Minute wird es Ihnen in diesem Prozess
um Demokratisierung der Medien gehen
auch die FDP beschäftigt sich mit dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ein
Reformpapier hat sich schon hat den
Titel ein moderner leistungsfähiger und
transparenter öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk und für die FDP-Fraktion
spricht nun Thomas Hacker
medienpolitischer Sprecher es ist ja
noch gar nicht so lange her da durften
oder mussten wir uns an einem
Freitagnachmittag in einer aktuellen
Stunde auf Antrag der AFD über den
öffentlichen Rundfunk unterhalten
wirklich Neues gab es damals nicht der
erste Redner versprach dass der zweite
reden etwas ankündigen Wolle und das tat
er dann auch er kündigte an dass seine
Fraktion einen Antrag in den Deutschen
Bundestag einbringt aha
der Rest war das bekannte Geschwurbel
der oft vorgetragene Hass auf
Journalisten und Medien schaffen wir das
Lamento über Ungerechtigkeiten und
unverständlich unverstanden sein das
Übliche halt die Kollegen vom rechten
Rand haben aber tatsächlich wortgehalten
sie haben einen Antrag angebracht kein
Antrag in dem Sie Ihre Vorstellungen und
Reformideen für die Medienlandschaft in
Deutschland aufzeigen vielleicht gibt es
die ja auch gar nicht stattdessen wollen
sie eine onkit-kommission einberufen
auch gut oder eben nicht denn wären die
bisherigen und Kommissionen die großen
Themen und Herausforderungen ihrer Zeit
einer umfassenden tiefen und
ausgewogenen Diskussionen Durchleuchtung
unterzogen ist das durch den
vorliegenden Antrag gar nicht erst
vorgesehen schon bei den zu
diskutierenden Fragestellungen werden
die Stichworte vorgegeben Haltung
Journalismus Mainstreaming selektive
Nachrichtenauswahl eben das was sie in
ihren Redebeiträgen schon immer
präsentiert haben eben das womit sie
glauben ihre filterblase zu befriedigen
sie stellen die deutsche medienordnung
in Frage und wollen die Legitimität des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
überprüfen Sie wollen die Axt Anlegen an
das Fundament unserer freien
pluralistischen medienordnungen wir
nicht Pressefreiheit Meinungsfreiheit
Staatsfeinde das gleichberechtigte
Nebeneinander von privaten und
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medienunternehmen
föderale Verantwortlichkeit all das ist
durch unser Grundgesetz geschützt und
wir werden es verteidigen
es ist kompliziert Abstimmungsprozesse
Staatsverträge Landes- und Bundesebene
und Europa aber gerade die föderale
deutsche medienordnung wurde in den
Gründungsjahren der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland aus den bitteren Erfahrungen
am Ende der Weimarer Republik gewählt
zum Schutz der Freiheit und der Vielfalt
natürlich verändern sich die
Medienlandschaften rasant nein danke
Zeitungsverlage sterben
ganze die jüngeren Generationen beziehen
ihre Informationen aus dem Netz begegnen
dort Fake News und Hasskampagnen unsere
Medienlandschaft ist durch disruption
geprägt die Sendeanstalten Verlag Häuser
und Medienunternehmer müssen selbst erst
eine Antwort darauf finden das betrifft
Programminhalte genauso wie
Geschäftsmodelle Voraussetzung für
Medien Vielfalt sind aber lebendige und
zahlreiche Medienhäuser und
Sendeanstalten es ist unverständlich das
Vorschläge zur Presseförderung immer
noch nicht vorliegen hier hat sich in
der letzten Wahlperiode bereits die
große Koalition lächerlich gemacht Herr
Habeck Frau Brandner ist
zwischenzeitlich auch weg Frau Roth
kommen sie endlich in die pushen mit
Gutachten allein und dem warten darauf
werden sie das Zeitungssterben nicht
verhindern die Zeit drängt und wer in
diesem Zusammenhang die Nase über
Anzeigenblätter mit redaktionellen
Inhalt rümpft hat keine Ahnung davon wie
die Informationsversorgung im länd den
Raum funktioniert ganze Generationen und
hier die Älteren haben im ländlichen
Raum genau diese Anzeigenblätter oft als
einzige Informationsquelle für regionale
Nachrichten der Bundesverband digital
Publisher und Zeitungsverleger hat Recht
wenn er die großen Herausforderungen der
medienordnung der Zukunft darum sieht ob
sich meinungsbildende qualitätsinhalte
auch in Zukunft noch unternehmerisch
lohnen und ja auch der öffentliche
Rundfunk muss sich der kritischen
diskussionsstellen die Vorschläge von
kundigen Privatpersonen wie Tom Burow
überhäufen sich und sind radikale als
vor einigen Monaten noch vorstellbar
aber auch hier tragen wir eine
Verantwortung Reformprozesse anzustoßen
die Diskussion mit den Ländern zu suchen
und gleichzeitig die Stärken des
öffentlichen Rundfunks nicht zu zerreden
keine onkel-kommission ersetzt was der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und die
Länder selbst leisten müssen gerade in
Zeiten von Polarisierung und
Desinformation müssen die Sendeanstalten
glaubhaft und breit informieren und ihre
zentralen Beiträge dafür leisten dass
wir eine offene vielfältige tolerante
und demokratisch gefestige Gesellschaft
bleiben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist unsere Aufgabe den rasanten
Veränderungsprozess in der weltweiten
Medienlandschaft vernünftig auch
regulatorisch zu begleiten es ist unsere
Verantwortung die Werte unseres
Grundgesetzes die Freiheitsrechte der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu verteidigen
ist unsere Pflicht durch eine
vielfältige lebendige Medienlandschaft
Informationsquellen für alle Menschen zu
ermöglichen für Jung und weniger Junge
in der Großstadt wie im ländlichen Raum
damit schützen wir Freiheit und Vielfalt
damit steigen wir unsere Demokratie
danke
Thomas Hacker war das hier in der
Debatte auf einer onkette-kommission zur
medienordnung eingesetzt werden soll
dass wir hier im Präsidium nicht alle
Zwischenrufe die bisher in dieser
Debatte gefallen sind akustisch hier
wahrnehmen konnten so habe ich mir das
vorabprotokoll hierher zur späteren
Prüfung bestellt und werde überprüfen ob
es Dinge gibt die in irgendeiner Weise
noch einmal zu würdigen sind das Wort
hat die Kollegin Katrin Budde für die
SPD katrin wurde es Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Kultur und Medien
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk ist
und wird feste Säule unserer
Medienlandschaft sein erst wichtig als
unabhängiges Medium das breite
gesellschaftliche Themen mit regionaler
Tiefe verbindet erst grundsätzlich nur
der breiten parteiunabhängigen
Informationen verpflichtet und natürlich
muss auch Unterhaltung dabei sein Sport
Kunst und Kultur und der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk ist
unverzichtbar für unsere Demokratie
gerade die Kombination aus einem starken
öffentlich-rechtlichen und starken
privaten Rundfunk sorgt in Deutschland
dafür dass es eine breite
Meinungsvielfalt gibt die
Meinungsfreiheit grundgesetzlich
geschützt bietet beiden die Möglichkeit
zu unabhängiger Berichterstattung
und mit der mit denen sich verändernden
medienkonsumgewohnheiten da beschäftigt
sich der öffentlich-rechtliche übrigens
von Anfang an ich war in alter
Funktionen mehrere Jahre im ZDF
Fernsehrat das Reagieren auf und
Verändern von Formaten seit dem Aufstieg
von Social Media und der Ausbreitung der
Online-Formate das war nie das Problem
das Problem war immer dass die
Konkurrenz zum öffentlich-rechtlichen
die privaten Medienmacher in den Gremien
saßen und sitzen und sie wollten und
haben das kenne ich aus eigenem Erleben
die Möglichkeit des
öffentlich-rechtlichen begrenzt zu
reagieren weil sie eben diese Konkurrenz
nicht wollten ich kann mich dann
zauberhafte Debatten erinnern
richtig ist aber auch dass alles was
lange in ziemlich ruhigen Bahnen und mit
guten finanzierungshintergrund läuft
Gefahr läuft träge zu werden und
angreifbar für Fehler und Fehlverhalten
und deshalb wird diesmal zu recht tiefer
und anders diskutiert wenn es um die
Reformen und Modernisierung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen geht die
Diskussionen sind stärker struktureller
Art inhaltsgetrieben und weniger nur
finanzierungsgetrieben und das ist gut
für mich steht die Frage die die AFD
aufwirft nach der Legitimität und
Notwendigkeit des öffentlich-rechtlichen
allerdings nicht diese Fragen sind für
mich beantwortet ja der
öffentlich-rechtliche ist legitim und ja
er ist notwendig für mich ist aber die
Idee von Herrn Burow auch wenn es wie so
oft in der Natur der Sache liegt dass
man solche grundlegenden
Veränderungsvorschläge erst am Ende der
eigenen Karriere im
öffentlich-rechtlichen macht aber wer
werfe da den ersten Stein
eine sehr grundsätzliche Diskussion zu
führen über Struktur und Inhalt und das
Erschließen von Synergien der
Zusammenlegung bestimmter Teile die
finde ich richtig und wichtig denn schon
jetzt verfängt ja das Gerede derjenigen
die den öffentlich-rechtlichen
grundsätzlichen Frage stellen und
abschaffen wollen für mich sind die
dahinterliegenden Absichten sehr
durchsichtig aber es verfängt leider bei
zu großen Teilen der Bevölkerung und
deshalb ist es wirklich dringend geboten
zwei Minuten vor zwölf und Vertrauen und
Akzeptanz für den zu dringend
notwendigen öffentlichen Rundgang
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk wieder
zu erarbeiten und danke an die AFD für
den Redebeitrag denn dadurch ist mir
noch mal sehr viel klarer geworden auch
hier öffentlich und es ist gemacht
worden klarer warum es ihnen wirklich
geht werden sie ja in der Begründung
sich noch auf verschiedene Zitate
berufen haben und die genutzt haben
haben Sie hier ganz klar gesagt worum es
Ihnen geht nämlich es passt ihnen nicht
was in der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk berichtet das wird keiner
komplett Kommission lösen können und
deshalb brauchen wir sie auch nicht
Katrin Budde war das hat hier unter
anderem die Rede des wdr-intendanten und
ard-vorsitzenden Tom Buhrow angesprochen
er hatte sich im Verein überseeclub in
Hamburg ja zu möglichen Reformen
geäußert hatte aber damals betont dass
er das nur als
Privatperson machen frau Präsidentin wir
versuchen es was die Redezeit anbetrifft
ich bin nicht geneigt mich bei jedem
hingeworfenen Stückchen jeweils immer
wieder aufs Neue aufzuregen manchmal ist
es eine Last vielleicht als Jurist zu
sagen man kommt mit der Prüfung relativ
kurz zu Ende dieser Antrag wäre
unzulässig das wären nur 20 Sekunden
Redezeit ist mir dann doch ein bisschen
zu wenig völlig in Ordnung wird jetzt so
eingestellt das war noch die Zeit die
Kollegin übrig gelassen hat
vielen Dank
aber man könnte da zu Ende kommen selbst
wenn man es
camoufliert mit dem Begriff Medien
Ordnung sind herzlichen Dank die
medienordnung ist durch das Grundgesetz
vorgegeben und ansonsten ist es eine
Zuständigkeit der Länder wir können uns
selbstverständlich Gedanken dazu machen
aber das Wort onkette aus dem
französischen von befragen befassen
untersuchen ist natürlich insofern
interessant weil man das Ergebnis ja
gleich vorneweg nimmt also was da
rauskommen soll steht dann in so einem
Antrag auch schon drin das hilft am Ende
des Tages tatsächlich nicht weiter und
es ist mir relativ egal wie diese
Diskussion läuft ob das Linz Profit sie
ist dass man eine Institution hat an der
man sich abarbeiten muss jeden Tag es
gab Zeiten bei da war doch kein einziges
Sofa im öffentlich-rechtlichen und
privaten Rundfunk ohne AFD zu denken und
bespielt von ihnen also zu sagen man
käme da nicht vor ist irgendetwas was
allenfalls noch mit realitätsverdrängung
zu tun und zu beantworten ist
jetzt geht das Stückchen weiter Herr
Frieser der statten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung des Abgeordneten freue mich
frau Präsidentin die Nachfragen und
zwischen bemerkenden der AFD haben die
in das Niveau der Debatte nicht gehoben
deshalb vielen herzlichen Dank aber nein
heute just zu diesem Augenblick war Herr
Plasberg bei Pioneer wann mit
Genehmigung zu zitieren doch auch ein
wirklich durchaus interessanter Geist
der da gleichzeitig mal gesteht er habe
letzten September die Grünen gewählt
aber der schon auch warnt vor dem was
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk tut
der gerne auch mal waren vor politisch
korrekten übereife der in der
Berichterstattung gerne mal in der
Flughöhe über das was den Lebensalltag
der Menschen ausmacht hinweg gleitet und
dass wir einen Reformbedarf haben der
übrigens ein Prozess ist
und Frau Kollegin Budde ich kann mich an
Diskussionen zwischen Union und SPD da
war die SPD von der Frage privater
Rundfunk nicht so wahnsinnig begeistert
ist schon Alter schon ein bisschen her
also dass ich was ändern kann und was
ändern muss hat jetzt erblich nicht erst
der Reformbedarf beim rbb gezeigt
sondern das ist hier wirklich auch
strukturelle Probleme gibt die eben
gerade nichts mit der Frage des Inhaltes
zu tun hat die drei Säulen es scheint
mir das pädagogische Prinzip der
Wiederholung zu sein es muss man halt
immer wieder sagen der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunker dann
Auftrag in drei soll das ist die
Information die Bildung und die
Unterhaltung all das müssen wir
vorfinden dass sie sich dabei um ein
Spannungsfeld handelt weil von den
ursprünglichen Sendeanstalten und auf
der anderen Seite den freien Printmedien
der Content ja mittlerweile nahezu nicht
mehr zu unterscheiden ist wenn sie auf
die medienzeiten des öffentlichen
rechtlichen rund losgehen und auf die
der privaten Medien oder
Printmedien dann sehen sie kaum mehr in
Unterschied und das Problem ist die Last
müssen leider Gottes die Mitarbeiter
tragen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
die sogenannten festen frei die müssen
dafür sorgen dass der Artikel dass die
Überschrift die unterüberschrift ist
Filmchen ist Bildchen und und und kommt
und das ist manchmal tatsächlich nicht
optimal weder bezahlt noch vom Zeitdruck
her zu akzeptieren das hat die Mitarbeit
der Politik in den Rundfunk reden nicht
besser gemacht bisher man darf sich also
schon die Frage stellen ist es der
richtige Ort in der politische
Mitwirkung an dieser Stelle da ist wir
müssen sagen dieser Reformbedarf muss
nicht nur dort diskutiert werden sondern
ja der muss auch öffentlich diskutiert
werden weil es wenigstens auch um die
Frage des Contents in den Mediatheken
geht über die Frage werden Nutzer
Gewogenheit wie bekomme ich an
Informationen die ich haben will des
lineare ist etwas was
generationenübergreifend nicht mehr so
sehr geschätzt wird da hinten wir
hinterher und diese Diskussion dürfen
wir uns aber nicht kaputt machen lassen
vom falschen inputus vom falschen
Auftakt und vom falschen Aufriss sondern
wir sollten konstruktiv an der
Weiterentwicklung der
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien
tatsächlich miteinander arbeiten vielen
Dank
danke zu einer todsintervention erhält
der Abgeordnete Frömming das Wort
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass sie
die Kurzintervention zulassen Herr
Kollege Friesen ich hätte Ihnen gerne
eine sachliche free sehr Verzeihung ja
vielen Dank ich hätte ihn gerne eine
sachliche Zwischenfrage gestellt aber
vielleicht hätte sie das aus dem Konzept
gebracht ich möchte Sie mich fragen
kennen Sie das Dokument mit dem Titel
laufende Aktivitäten der Ressource und
Behörden gegen Desinformation
wenn Sie das sich mal anschauen
vielleicht haben sie es ja angeschaut
das liest sich so wie aus dem Kasten der
Verschwörungstheorie darin wird
beschrieben wie Behörden
Bundesministerien und so weiter ganz
konkret mit den Medien die ja frei und
unabhängig berichten sollen zusammen
kooperieren um meine bestimmte
öffentliche Meinung herzustellen ich
habe gedacht das kann gar nicht wahr
sein das ist so ein Dokument gibt und
dass unsere Bundesregierung die
Ministerien so etwas machen und habe
deshalb eine Nachfrage an die
Bundesregierung gestellt ob denn dieses
Dokument echt sei und siehe da die
Bundesregierung hat bestätigt dass
Dokument ist echt in diesem Dokument
wird übrigens weiterhin einen
sogenannter Liebe freundebrief erwähnt
der nur an bestimmte Abgeordnete dieses
Parlaments geschickt worden ist
interessanterweise natürlich nicht an
die Abgeordneten der afd-fraktion
interessanterweise sehr geehrter Kollege
Friese auch nicht an die Abgeordneten
der CDU ich weiß es sind sie jetzt auch
keine lieben Freunde mehr also Kollege
friesa wenn Sie das hören was ich Ihnen
jetzt dargestellt habe bleiben sie dann
immer noch bei der Meinung so wie ihre
Vorredner auch dass doch eigentlich
alles mit unserem öffentlichen Rundfunk
und der
Staatsferne bzw Nähe hier zum Besten
bestellt sei
sie haben die Möglichkeit zu Antwort der
Empfehlung von Kollegen wanderwitz zu
folgen soll ich einfach Nein sagen aber
es kommt dann doch etwas kurz rüber Frau
Präsident ich habe mich bemüht die
Redezeit einzuhalten das ist wirklich
nicht meine nicht meine Verantwortung
also ich verlange dir nicht von jedem
dass er zuhört auch nicht bei solchen
reden ich verlange auch nicht dass er
den Inhalt sofort begreift auch nicht
bei solchen reden will aber nicht
arrogant werden an dieser Stelle keiner
der Redner hier hat betont dass alles in
Ordnung ist also da muss man dann schon
wirklich auch geneigt sein in eine
Diskussion miteinander zu treten das ist
das eine das ist Fehler gibt das ist
selbstverständlich und deshalb wenn sie
zugehört hätten habe ich jetzt in der
Tat mich eines Fremden Zitates bedient
bei Herrn Plasberg der sagt politische
übereife der zumal auch spürbar wird ist
etwas wovon der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk übrigens wie andere Medien auch
nicht gefallen ist das erhöht gerade
Kontrolle die wir als Parlament die wir
als Politik haben und deshalb hat es
überhaupt keinen Sinn alles auszusorgen
wir geben jede Form von politischer
Verantwortung ab wir haben schon mal die
Frage der Finanzierung ausgeschlossen
macht jetzt eine Kommission sie machen
den Vorschlag nehmt es doch in der onkit
Kommission also wir müssen uns als
Politik schon selber drüber einig werden
wie wir die Kontrolle zwar nicht die
inhaltliche sondern ausschließlich die
logistische Kontrolle tatsächlich der
Reformbedürftigkeit des öffentlichen
Rundfunks Regeln dafür braucht es
tatsächlich ihres Hinweis ist nicht
danke
ich schließe die Aussprache in der
soweit also die Debatte zu einer
onkette-kommission zur medienordnung
dieser Antrag der afd-fraktion wird
jetzt in den Ausschuss für Kultur und
Medien federführend überwiesen viele
Politikerinnen und Politiker aus diesem
Ausschuss haben sich ja auch schon in
der Debatte geäußert und können das dann
noch im Ausschuss vertiefen